♪
♪.
TOMI: WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW" THE NIGHTMARE
BEFORE CHRISTMAS THE AUTOMAKER
THAT BUILDS JEEPS IS CUTTING
MORE THAN A THOUSAND JOBS IN A
MANUFACTURING PLANT IN ILLINOIS.
THE REASON THE HIGH COST OF
SWITCHING TO ELECTRIC AND
ANOTHER COST SAVING MEASURE THE
COMPANY IS MOVING ITS FACTORY
OUT OF THE U.S. AND TO MEXICO.
THE DEFINITION OF BUILD BACK
BETTER FOR OTHER COUNTRIES
INCLUDING MEXICO.
MAYBE EVEN CHINA.
WE'RE GOING TO DIG INTO THAT BUT
A LOT OF FOLKS ARE UNAWARE THAT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES,
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY OVER
THE LONGEVITY OF THEIR EXISTENCE
TO MAKE MORE ADMISSIONS TO MAKE
AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE THAN AN
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE.
I DON'T OF THE GREEN COMMUNITY
WANTS TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BUT
IT'S A VERY REAL THING.
>> THEY DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE
ELECTRICITY BY ITSELF COMES FROM
FOSSIL FUELS, NATURAL GAS, COAL,
ALL THESE DIFFERENT THINGS, YOU
DON'T FLICK A SWITCH AND GET
ELECTRICITY SO PEOPLE COULD
EXPECT ADMISSIONS AND SEE THEIR
PRICES GO UP BUT BACK TO THE
PRODUCTION OF THE CARS, THE
BATTERIES ARE HUGE PROBLEM NOT
ONLY CHEMICALS THAT THEY USED TO
PRODUCE THEM BUT THE WASTE THAT
THEY CREATE WHAT YOU SUPPOSED TO
DO WHEN THEY DIE AFTER THEY DIE
FAIRLY QUICKLY AND BY THE WAY WE
GET MOST OF THE BATTERIES FROM
CHINA.
WE DO NOT MAKE THEM HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES SOBER SWITCHING
OVER TO SOMETHING THAT IS REALLY
NOT GOOD HELP JOB GROWTH IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS IS A SAD STORY.
AHEAD OF CHRISTMAS BIDEN
PROMISED US THE GREEN JOBS,
WHERE ARE THEY INSTEAD PEOPLE
GETTING LAID OFF.
THE ADMINISTRATION SAID WE
CREATED 10 MILLION JOBS, WE
CRATED 10 MILLION JOBS THOSE
WERE JOBS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
THAT WERE BRIEFLY OFF-LINE AND
NOW THEY'RE TAKING CREDIT FOR
THEM.
THEY HAVE NOT CREATED THE NEW
JOBS THAT THEY PROMISED US.
TOMI: WHAT BRINGS ME SOMEONE
FROM SOUTH DAKOTA FROM THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE BIDEN SAID
HE WOULD CREATE THE GREEN NEW
JOBS BUT PEOPLE LIKE BIDEN AND
JOHN KERRY NEVER GOING TO GET TO
IN A MINUTE, THEY WERE OKAY WITH
ELIMINATING ENTIRE JOB SECTORS
AND HIGH-PAYING JOBS FOR
AMERICANS BUT THEY'RE NOT OKAY
WITH ELIMINATING ANYTHING OUT OF
THEIR LUXURY LIFESTYLE.
JOHN KERRY THINKS WERE NOT
MOVING FAST ENOUGH ON THE GREEN
AGENDA.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE CAN'T RUN AROUND INTO ONE
DEAL HERE IN ANOTHER DEAL HERE.
IT IS AND CAN BE FAST ENOUGH.
SO EVERYTHING HAS TO ACCELERATE.
AND BY VAST AMOUNTS.
IF YOU THINK SUPPLY CHAINS WERE
INTERRUPTED BY COVID WAIT UNTIL
YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
HUNDRED MILLION PEOPLE ARE
MOVING IN AFRICA BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T LIVE THERE ANYMORE, THEY
CAN PRODUCE FOOD.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH WATER.
IT IS TOO HOT.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING INDICATORS
AND THAT IN VARIOUS PARTS OF THE
WORLD.
>> WIPEOUT JOBS A LITTLE BIT
FASTER FOR JOHN KERRY PLEASE
BECAUSE HE IS NOT HAPPY WITH THE
PACE OF THE WAY THAT THEIR
MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION.
IT'S REALLY HYPOCRITICAL WHEN I
HEAR THINGS LIKE THIS FROM JOHN
KERRY.
I ALSO LOOK TO OTHER NATIONS
THAT ARE CERTAINLY NOT LESSENING
THEIR ADMISSIONS CHINA BEING ONE
AND THAT TIES BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL STORY WOULD CHEAPEN
THESE JOBS, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT THAT.
>> JEEP IS AN AMERICAN ICON THE
IDEA THAT IT'S GOING TO BE MADE
IN MEXICO IS ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS.
JOHN KERRY HAS NO CREDIBILITY ON
THIS ISSUE WHATSOEVER.
TALK ABOUT ONE BUSINESS JOKE
DEAL AT A TIME.
PART OF WHAT THE BIDEN HERE IS
ADMINISTRATION WHICH JOHN KERRY
IS PART OF GAVE $200 MILLION TO
THIS MICRO VAST, MICRO VAST IS
GOOD TO BE THIS SOLYNDRA OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
$200 MILLION, 69% OF THE REVENUE
COMES OUT OF CHINA.
THERE TIED TO THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD GET
$200 MILLION.
REMEMBER WHEN THE DEMOCRATS
PASSED OUT OF THE HOUSE AND
SENATE BIDEN CITED $300 BILLION
THAT'S GOING TO BE RUN BY WHO,
JOHN PODESTA OF ALL PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT HAS A
POLITICAL TIED TO IT.
TOMI: NOT AT ALL, THAT WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN.
[LAUGHTER]
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DEMOCRATS AT LARGE HAVE PUT A
LOT OF STAKE INTO THE CLIMATE
AGENDA TELLING EVERYBODY WE CAN
GET RID OF JOBS, WE CAN HURT OUR
ECONOMY, IT'S OKAY IN THE NAME
OF FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE.
BIDEN SAYS EVERYTHING'S GOOD TO
BE OKAY.
HE SAID WERE SO OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
JOB GROWTH WHEN HE WAS IN
PHOENIX AND OUT OF THE BORDER
LET'S LISTEN TO OUR PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT I MOST EXCITED ABOUT IS
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO FEEL A
SENSE OF OPTIMISM.
AS THEY SEE THE IMPACT OF THE
ACHIEVEMENTS IN THEIR OWN LIVES.
IT'S GOING TO ACCELERATE MONTH
AHEAD.
MY DAD USED TO HOT HAVE A
SAYING.
YOU SAID JOB IS ABOUT A LOT MORE
THAN A PAYCHECK JOEY IT IS ABOUT
YOUR DIGNITY IT IS ABOUT
RESPECT.
IT'S ABOUT LOOKING YOUR CHILD IN
THE EYE AND SAYING HONEY IT'S
GOING TO BE OKAY.
JACKIE: IS IT GOING TO BE OKAY,
DO YOU THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE BUYING WHAT OUR PRESIDENT IS
SELLING.
GIANNO: I'M STUCK ON THIS THAT
HE SAID ACHIEVEMENTS THAT ARE
GOING, THE UNAPPOINTED PRESIDENT
CONTINUES TO RING, THE ONLY
PRESIDENT THAT COMES IN ON DAY
ONE AND SLASHES $2 BILLION WORTH
OF WAGES AND THAT THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE.
HE SAID AS YOU MENTIONED THERE
WILL BE GREEN NEW JOBS THAT WE
SEEN PEOPLE COME ON AIR THAT
WERE WORKING ON THE PIPELINE THE
SAID IT DOESN'T EXIST.
THERE IS NO GREEN NEW JOBS.
THIS REALLY HURTS ME WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH JEEP BECAUSE IT'S
IN MY HOME STATE.
70 CORPORATIONS HAVE LEFT,
CITADEL HAS LEFT, A LOT OF MAJOR
BUSINESSES WHICH WERE ECONOMIC
DRIVERS FOR THE STATE OF
ILLINOIS ARE GONE AND THIS IS
ANOTHER ONE LEAVING AND ALSO TO
THE POINT OF THE GREEN JOBS IN
THEIR PUSHING THE EYE IDEOLOGY
ALMOST LOOKING GAVIN NEWSOM.
WORKING A BAND GAS CARS BY 2035.
ONLY ELECTRIC, THAT'S ALL WERE
DOING BUT IN THE SAME WEEK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING DON'T
CHARGE ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
IT WOULD BE LAUGHABLE IF IT
WASN'T SO INSANE.
TOMI: HE'S ALSO GOING AFTER
STYROFOAM AND THEY'RE GOING
AFTER GAS POWERED LEAF BLOWERS.
GIANNO: THE GOOD NEWS I DON'T
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES ANYMORE.
JACKIE: A QUICK ECONOMICS.
TO FIGHT BIDEN'S INFLATION
JEROME POWELL IS GOING TO HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO RAISE RATES AND
HE BROADCASTED THAT THAT IS
GOING TO BE A PROBLEM FOR THE
LABOR MARKET MORE THAN 2 MILLION
PEOPLE WILL LOSE THEIR JOBS AND